you've got a skull
oh he's missed it
that is terrible
[Music]
hi i'm marcus rashford and this is rape
my skills for sport bible
across into the box
some bad defending
[Music]
oh that's beautiful that is beautiful
and i think he's just done it done
instinct uh
as soon as he's hit he knows it's got a
chance
yeah that was not yeah
that was class he's even injured two
players
that was good that and yeah he's made
him turn his hips and i think he's
actually injured him
and then after that he's just second
nature to him and he's he's fake shotted
a few of them
and then it's a good finish as well
nice turn oh another nice turn
oh he's on fire this kid
oh oh that's great i feel sorry for the
keeper though
well the chip's the best thing because
you know if you beat all the players
it looks good but then the chips like
finishes off a beautiful move
from start to finish it's great skill
great confidence
that was nice you've got a score
oh he's missed it
that is terrible the the chip balling
behind is perfect
the run's good everything's good until
the last until the last moment
and he's got three options as well and
he just chose the wrong guy
oh it's obvious it's a bad mess ball
to know they'll put it away hopefully
oh nice that's nice efficient
you know he done he's done his skill and
then he put it in the back of the net so
now everything's just efficient if you
look from when he does his skill i think
it's on he only has four touches in that
tight space and he's got a lot of bodies
around him as well
oh that looks so
do you know what what do you know he's
great heart great determination
who would you least want to take one of
those shots from in the team that united
definitely not paul bruno
you don't want anyone shooting at you
from that close really
and then you're taking it there it's
it's just not what you want
that's beautiful technique overhead
kicks are so like
for a skill that's that difficult they
actually scored quite often i think
and yeah things look better when they're
left footed anyway
it's a brilliant goal but i just think
that there's no way you should be
scoring from that
i've got to put some fault on the on the
keyboard
if you look at the beginning you should
be able to see the keeper already and
you can barely see him because he should
be
trusting the the wall and like just
protecting his side of the goal it's
you can't take anything away from the
finish it's a great finish but for me
personally
you should never be able to score keep
aside as a takeoff
it's it's a brilliant goal but as a
keeper the keeper's gotta be
disappointed there
so in in third place is the the young
boy who
done the half maradona and then the
maradona
um any fake shot with his right foot
fake shot of his left foot
and then dinked it to the back post and
it it went over the keeper's head
in second place is the
one in the orange top when he injured
the two lads and then put it in the
in the top corner um you know he's done
two stepovers
made a guy injure himself and then he's
fake shotted one cut inside of another
and then put it in the top corner and
then my favorite one is when
he's tried to play through ball he's
lost the ball and then
with loads of bodies around him he only
took four touches
and he done a maradona took it past one
guy
shifted the ball and then a quick sharp
finish into the bottom corner
i think that one was my favorite one i
am marcus rashford and that was rape my
skills
for sport bible
oh goal of the year goal of the year
the person that scored the goal he had
the
argument with the goalkeeper before the
game
oh that was a great on goal have you
ever done anything like that not yet
no yet i hope i won't